look i'm so worried about you right now
the savings rate this month hit a low of
2.7
this is a unbelievable and ridiculous
warning sign that i told you about last
week
the person that has 236 dollars invest
it all in yourself you're already broke
don't hold on to 236 dollars our parents
they taught us to save money
i want to bank cash man i need money i
need emergency funds
a safety net is one of the first goals
any investors should establish and fund
we recommend that everyone should save
regularly towards some kind of safety
net doesn't make any sense save your
money
prepare for a rainy day it [ __ ] don't
rain here i need to treat money like
it's sacred
[Music]
the savings rate in this country was
over six and a half percent
for 30 years now it's collapsed again
what are you doing
i'll never forget these guys pay 12 000
each to sit in that chair three days i
gotta look at their ugly faces
look man you're spending money on junk
when you don't need it look at my little
look at my little my little things man i
got i know guys walking around five and
six hundred dollar headphones and i got
my little freebies that came
came with my phone wow what's the
difference so this is a 13 passenger
gulf stream
uh it retails for about 61 million
dollars
truth is most people don't like money i
know they don't like money you know how
i know they don't like money
because as soon as you get something you
get rid of you buy [ __ ] with it
i mean it's crazy when you start putting
stuff on a jet
it's bizarre like this door was not in
here this door right here
believe it or not cost 850 000
to put in america is back to the savings
rate
that it was at back when we had this
problem in 2008
when people were buying porsches and
cars and country clubs
dude it was out of hand uh 10 years ago
all they used in these planes was
really dark heavy wood um probably cost
a million dollars to replace the wood
you know my father told me when i was
six years old he said
watch the pennies the dollars will take
care of themselves
okay help me out here penny saved this
a penny is a penny okay your mama got
real complicated here
a penny is a penny and if you spend time
with them
you'll end up with nothing when you
watch pennies and nickels and dimes and
quarters
when you watch that you're going to pay
attention to the bigger flows
people that are not disciplined with
money don't end up with money
people that waste money on dumb things
don't end up with money there's
something universal
about money waste it somebody else gets
it so
if you're down to your last thousand
dollars this this offer today is 9.97
grant cardone.com for it's like a shark
okay yeah you're down a guy's sitting
there right now
watching this and i'm i got my last
grand dude and i got christmas coming
should he spend it on this absolutely
i'll tell you the same thing